عن سيطره ضباع الغرب وانتزع الدب الروسي
زر التحكم في ماسات افريقيا عنوه رئيس
النيجر على مرمى رصاص الاعدام واحتاج لويس
يصرخون ودر بنا لقد باعنا الامريكان
والعمسام يبتسم ويكون في خبز
معذره باريس فلستم الورقه الرابحه
1500 جندي فرنسي في مرمى النيران وقاده
انقلاب النيجر يسخرون من تهديد واشنطن
ومبعوثه البيت الابيض تعود من افريقيا
بخفي حنين تهديد بالحرب يتحول الى مسدس
صوت وبوتين يغرد بعيدا انها ليست النهايه
والعقاب لم ياتي بعد ساكسر انفسكم في
افريقيا كما كسرته في الشرق الاوسط وشعر
المرحله الجديد اصبح كسرينه السيارات احذر
امريكا ترجع الى الخلف هل سيقوم قاده
النيجر الجدد بالتخلص من الرئيس بازوم
ويضعون الغرب امام الامر الواقع ولماذا
تهمت باريس واشنطن بالخيانه العظمى وكيف
احرج قاده انقلاب النيجر مبعوثه واشنطن
على اراضيهم وهل ستتراجع عن التدخل
العسكري وتؤكد انتصار بوتين في ملحمه
افريقيا المصيريه لتعرف اجابه كل تلك
الاسئله تابع الفيديو للنهايه اعدام
الرئيس وتربيط الاسود
انقلاب النيجر العسكري كل حسابات الغرب
الكل ترتعد فرائسه خوفا من سيطره بوتين
على ساحل افريقيا الغربي وتكرار سيناريو
مالي وبوركينا فاسو الدب الروسي ينتزع ورق
اللعب بالقوه ويعلنها اماما سيفرق الورق
على الجميع بعد الان ضباع الغربي يحاولون
استغلال ايديهم الخفيه في افريقيا لتعلن
مجموعه ايكوس لقاده الانقلاب مهله للتراجع
حتى السادس من اغسطس الجري والا سيتدخلون
عسكريا في النيجر ويقلبون كل شيء راسا على
عقب ولكن ما هي عشره ايام تمر على انتهاء
المولى لم يتراجع قاده الانقلاب ولم يجرؤ
احد على التدخل العسكري في النيجر جوهره
افريقيا وبحر اليورانيوم العميد ووصل
احكام قاده الانقلاب قبضتهم لدرجه اعلانهم
انهم سيحاكمون الرئيس محمد بتهمه الخيانه
العظمى مردا منهم على مناشدته المتكرره
لدول اجنبيه من اجل التدخل العسكري في
البلاد واعادته الى الحكم مره اخرى ما
يعني ان بازون سيواجه غالبا حكما بالاعدام
واغلاق صفحته الى الابد ووضع باريس واشنطن
امام الامر الواقع كل هذا دون ان تستطيع
باريس تحريك جندي واحد للوقوف امامهم وكان
احفاد لويس حلفائهم في افريقيا يقولون في
انفسهم الخوف ليس من جيش النيجر بل من
الدب الروسي الذي يقف خلفه متعطشا للبطش
باي متهور يقترب من منطقه نفوذه الجديده
ودعني اقول لك يا عزيزي ان الوضع في
النيجر ليس مجمدا كما يبدو ظاهريا بل انما
يحدث اليوم يوضح تراجع واستسلام واشنطن
نفسها امام طموح رجل موسكو القوي لدرجه ان
البيت الابيض قام بفعله اثرت جنون قصر
الاليزي وجعل دماغه يتهم بايدن بالخيانه
العظمى وتركه في منتصف الطريق يا الهي هل
انتقلت ساحه المعركه من اراضي اسود
افريقيا الى اراضي ضباع الغرب ما الذي
يحدث اهانه مبعوثه واشنطن يبدو ان ابناء
العم سام يحاولون التعامل مع الوضع الجديد
واستغلال كل شيء لتحقيق مصالحهم فبعد
انتهاء مولة ووسط انتظار العالم لما سيفعل
حلفاء فرنسا وامريكا ارسلت واشنطن مساعده
وزير خارجيتها
لمساومه قاده الانقلاب متبعه سياسه
الترغيب والترهيب فمن ناحيه تحاول كسب
المجلس العسكري الهجري في صف واشنطن ومن
ناحيه اخرى تهددهم بقطع المعونه الامريكيه
عن النيجر اذا ما استمروا في بصف موسكو
ولكن لم تجد العجرفه الامريكيه سبيلا مع
جيش النيجر وتم استقبال مبعوثه واشنطن
استقبال مهينا فلم يسمح لها بمقابله زعيم
النيجر الحالي عبد الرحمن شياني اصلا ولا
حتى مقابله محمد بازوم فابلغت قائدا
عسكريا في الجيش بتهديد واشنطن والذي رد
عليها قائلا تهديدكم لن يهز شعره في
رؤوسنا افعل ما تريدون عادت مبعوثه اقوى
دوله في العالم من النيجر بخفي حنين
ليجتمع بعد ذلك قاده مجموعه اكواس لبحث
خطط التدخل العسكري في النيجر ولكن
المدهشه ان هذا الاجتماع انتهى على
التراجع عن التدخل العسكري ومحاوله حل
الازمه بالطرق السلميه خصوصا وان الدول
ضمن التحالف اعلنت صراحه لانضمامها لصف
انقلاب النيجر مثل مالي وبوركينا حتى نيجي
ريا التي قامت بالضربه الاولى وقطعت
الكهرباء عن الهجر واظلمتها رفض برلمانها
التدخل عسكريا واعلن انه ليس هناك الا
الطرق الدبلوماسيه لحل الازمه كما ان
واشنطن اعلنت صراحه ولاول مره رفضها
التدخل العسكري في النيجر على عكس باريس
التي ترى ان التدخل العسكري هو الحل
الوحيد لتحرير حليفها الوثيق محمد بازوم
ولكن لماذا غيرت واشنطن رايها في لحظه
خنجر واشنطن في
ظهر باريس
ام يكاد احفاد لويس يستفيقون من صفات الدب
الروسي لهم في غرب افريقيا ليتلقوا طعنه
قاتله من العمزان في ظهرهم ففي الوقت الذي
يعمل فيه مكون على لملمه اشلاء والعوده
الى ساحه المعركه من جديد مسنودا على قوه
بايدن الضاربه غدر بايدن بحليفه وقام
بتعيين سفيره لامريكا لدى النيجر ووافق
عليها الكونجرس بعد يوم واحد من الانقلاب
الامر الذي جعل الدخانه يخرج من انفي واذن
مكون من شده الغيظ واتهم احفاد لويس ابناء
العم سام بالغدر بهم وعدم الوضوح في
سياستهم تجاه الازمه ففي نفس الوقت الذي
كانت تردد فيه واشنطن بالانقلاب وتدعو
لتحرير الرئيس بازوم كان هو نفسه الوقت
الذي عينت فيه سفيرا امريكيا بالنيجر
وكانها تعترف ضمنيا بالحكومه الجديده
وتتلاعب بباريس وتبيع الجميع من اجل مص
ولكن لماذا استشاطت باريس غضبا من موقف
واشنطن الضبابي في الازمه اظلام عاصمه
النور ما فعله ابناء العم سام في النيجر
جعل احفاد لويس يشعرون بالبرد اكثر من اي
وقت مضى واشنطن اعلنت مؤخرا ولاول مره لا
للتدخل العسكري في النيجر الدبلوماسيه فقط
هي الحل لترد اكوس سمعا وطاعه فقد الغتك
واسال الاجتماع الذي كانت قررت عقده في
غانا الاسبوع المقبل لمناقشه سبل التدخل
العسكري في النيجر ولكن هناك من يصرخ
وحيدا انه ماكون فرفض امريكا ومجموعه
يعني تعرض حياتي 1500 جندي فرنسي في جوهره
افريقيا للخطر بل هناك ما هو افضل مع
الوضع الجديد ستجد باريس نفسها تقف وحيده
امام الني الرافضين لوجودهم وجيوش مالي
وبوركينا فاسو نايكا عن جحافلر الجائعين
الذين يتحينون الفرصه لنشر لحم الديك
الفرنسي وحتى الدبلوماسيه لن تكون حلا
بالنسبه لفرنسا فاذا تراجع احفاد لويس عن
الحل العسكري لن يقف بوتين بما فاز به
وسيذهب نحو وجهته التاليه والتي ستكون في
الاغلب تشاد واذا تهور ماكرون
فغالبا سيقع جيشه ضحيه لمخالب الدب الروسي
الذي يبدو وكانه ينتظر تلك اللحظه بفارغ
الصبر يبدو اننا قريبا سنقول في صوت واحد
وداعا فرنسا وسيتحول الديك الفرنسي من
عملاق مخيف الى وجبه شهيه على مائده طعام
الدول العظمى والسؤال لكم مشاهدينا هل
سيستطيع احفاد لويس اقناع الغمسام بالتدخل
العسكري واعاده هيبه في افريقيا ام ان
العقد قد انفرط وانتهى لقب عاصمه النور
الى الابد
[موسيقى]